yeah hello and welcome to this video
attack GM Julian option have him again
here as an opponent let's see what is
coming up with yeah this is a pretty
decent line for black sir offbeat but
not bad at all g6 do you play I think
this one g3 is also possible of course
fairly flexible setup for both sides I
have pretty bad score against him and
spoiled some good positions let's see
what happens in this game ok so I don't
know what do I go e4 here I really like
to have this broad center and give my
bishop liquid square i am ok this is a
king's indian here without them without
the light squared Bishop the thing is
what is black splenium f5 is not so easy
to play yeah I think I'm preparing the
typical f4 counter punch and five yeah
this is the kind of thing they always
play that it's don't never believed in
it I think white should always be quite
substantially better but it's it's not
easy to prove of course in a blitz game
yeah the position opens up and black has
terrible light squares absolutely
terrible okay I'm not doing I really
don't care about the beep on actually
596 is the main point in this position
no I not can check me with King edge to
is a useful move anyway
Jim yeah again this is getting to a
situation where it's about converting a
good position not like converting a win
or something but why this definitely in
good shape um just have to play it
correctly hmm let's see how yeah i can i
can just take these six this is one
thing I just don't know if this is the
best way to play rook takes f 4 will be
the answer so I'll go for what I
originally wanted to do go for you six
and yeah just 96 SS looks good so let's
do it yeah I can take b7 I don't know if
it is a useful pawn to take ultimately i
will go to d5 okay I'll out wrap this
just not for not so much for the poet I
want to be file it's good to have the B
file open
yeah this is a move that ahead on the
radar but couldn't quite believe in it
okay I'm should be five yeah threatening
you seven check yeah yeah can I just
take g5 here or not heavy seven check
check always what take here look f7 is
also good yeah this disorder should be
good right let's take and now I have a
look at Bishop takes e5 Bishop g5 if I
take on g5 he takes it u7 check doesn't
lead to much if I take a five and then
look to f7 you can check me once but I
go to h1 look f seven and then and
admins come on don't don't tell me that
this doesn't win
he only has one single check on be too
okay so yeah I still go down check so if
I now and sorry if I now play Queen to
d3 i'm threatening made and he cannot
cover that you can go if for Queen takes
like Bishop g7 okay when you can always
check me here this is what I have to
have to to look at I also happy seven of
course I mean does he have a move
against e7 I'm threatening you can
sacrifice the Queen that that's actually
possible it's a check okay 23 let's go
Quinn d3 then I'm down to one minute
something
again you can go a form Queen takes
Bishop g7 but then e seven that should
really win and a queen is covering be
one Bishop g7 e7 I'd resign select or
right here okay yeah so I'm happy to
have refuted that I simply don't believe
in this f5 I mean you cannot give up the
light squared Bishop and then open open
this up it really feels completely anti
positional to me like this this cannot
be great i mean let's see what the
engine says about it it gives it about
equal yeah you have a couple of options
you can also go here and here it's tough
the same i mean i don't think this is a
good Kings Indian giving up the light
squared Bishop and then playing with at
five I don't believe it so let's see
what the engine is giving here is ok for
black Bishop b5 ok that's an entirely
different approach or first check and
then but should be five even though it
looks strange to get give white the h 2
square I mean why does happy to have the
King down now let's let's analyze this
for a moment i think i will take brooke
will take and just normal most the thing
is this is weak he's got weak squares i
have always suspended idea to go in
there and my bishop blue becomes strong
piece either after me taking on e6 or
age for Bishop age three so this is why
i don't believe this okay the engine is
just giving widest slide edge but it's
definitely nice for wider yeah so here
he grabbed the poor matt j
just it just feels very dangerous so
Nyjah 7 looked like the only move at now
I just I just went in and now everything
opens up and stay angle is very strong
Bishop d5 immediately yeah maybe I was
thinking yeah get the bond back but it's
probably true am Bishop h6 also wins
already but it's that bad I don't
believe it's bad no it's also winning
it's just too bad this position Bishop
g5 was winning okay with this also
should win i don't i don't think there
is a way out there who have seven a
check and queen h5 yeah Queen h5 I
thought you can always check me even
more check check huh okay yeah okay i
can i can actually look I can do this
did that move I didn't think about it
all that I can retreat the bishop okay
that that's very clean win but that also
wins simply no defense yeah the Kings
Indian a break with f5 I think it's
always very very dangerous if you have
given up your light squared Bishop like
happen in this game ok guys thanks for
watching